en pleine épidémie de coronavirus si
tous les yeux sont tournés vers les
soignants et les chercheurs qui tentent
d'endiguer l'épidémie d'autres
commencent déjà à se poser des questions
sur l'après car de nombreux indépendants
comme les restaurateurs ou les chefs de
petites et moyennes entreprises sont
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt complet est dans
une situation économique parfois
catastrophiques si le chef de l'état a
promis un coup de pouce financier
aujourd'hui c'est indépendant compte sur
les assurances pour gérer la casse
sauf que voilà rien n'est moins sûr
alors qu'aujourd'hui on estime les
pertes des restaurateurs français à
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
chacun se demande après l'orage qui va
payer
le problème des assurances et que les
contrats ne couvre que les événements
qui sont prévisibles et les pandémies
n'en font pas partie comme l'expliquent
charloton froid journaliste de bfm le
problème du covin 19 c'est que c'est une
pandémie
on estime que les pandémies comme les
accidents nucléaires interviennent une
fois par siècle
le risque est donc impossible à estimer
et donc non assurables une situation
inquiétante car chacun se demande
aujourd'hui comment sans aide extérieure
il sera possible de rouvrir à leur
restaurant entreprises commerces les
assurances vont elles pouvoir rembourser
[Musique]
alors ça ça chaussures là je les vois
tous là il est en train d'écouter le
sujet ça intéresse tout le monde toutes
les personnes qui nous regardent se
disent est ce qu'elles vont pouvoir être
remboursés
voilà les les entreprises c'est vrai que
j'ai vu mathieu qui était très intéressé
par le sujet on a la chance d'avoir
julien frier au comparateur d'assurances
sur internet qui est avec nous merci
d'être avec nous parce que généralement
on n'y comprend rien à ces histoires
d'assurance donc merci jérôme julien est
là alors que vous appelez jérôme et
c'est julien merci julien beau gosse à
julien pas mal à tanger regard en sortie
du jour hi fi des bosses à sebha bravo
bravo julien pour le physique déjà tu es
ce que est ce que les entreprises vont
être indemnisés suite aux pertes causées
par le corona est ce que les assurances
vont pouvoir tout prendre en charge
parce qu'on dit les assurances elles ont
explosé lorsque c'est possible ou pas en
fait ça va être très compliqué parce
qu'il ya alors déjà je suis pas sûr un
donc je vais d'abord prendre parti pour
pour qui que ce soit je laissais d'être
factuel mais dans les faits il ya deux
choses qui sont pas assurés c'est la
guerre et la pandémie ça c'est la
premier point ça c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on lit si on cherche à le lire dans
les contrats canton le signe pourquoi
parce que c'est tout le monde qui va
être touchée donc c'est pas quelque
chose assure en revanche les assureurs
sont en train
d'avoir des démarches hyper solidaire
hyper généreuse vis-à-vis de beaucoup de
choses c'est les seuls à avoir participé
autant au fond dead qui a mis en place
l'état mais effectivement pour l'instant
en plus ils ne savent même pas à quelle
hauteur il va falloir indemniser puisque
on sait pas quand est-ce que les cachets
voilà il paraît qu'on estime le coût des
pertes pour les entreprises françaises à
50 milliards d'euros
donc forcément pour indemniser toutes
les entreprises ça va être compliqué
comment ils vont faire tous les
restaurateurs tous les to du tout les
gens là qui nous regardent tous les gens
qui sont concernés
ils vont ils vont être aidés de
différentes manières et vraiment les
assureurs vont vont y participer mais
ils pourront pas être comment dire sauvé
par les assureurs ils n'ont pas cotisé
pour ça et effectivement c'est ce sera
pas à hauteur de la totalité de la perte
puisque vous l'avez dit 50 millions de
50 milliards
c'est impossible à assumer pour les
assureurs est ce que maintenant il va
avoir une clause sur les pandémies sur
les contrats d'assurance c'est beau
c'est prévu c'est quelque chose qui est
en train d'être travaillé parce qu'en
fait la question justement c'est pas est
ce que il y en aura une mais c'est quand
est-ce qu'il y en aura une
avant la pandémie on se disait que ça
arrivera jamais non on va on va
l'anticiper
les gens vont être obligés de cotiser à
ça parce que je vous aurais posé la
question il ya un an
la normale m 5000 euros à l'année pour
être assurés contre une pandémie ou en
lorraine rami a bien sûr exactement mais
dites-moi les assurances elles font des
économies en temps parce que personne ne
pensait à sa voiture donc a pas
d'accident comme ça mais non je pensais
à ça donc elles elles font des économies
est ce qu'elle peut faire des prix aussi
en ce moment les assurances que les
personnes peuvent appeler leurs
assureurs et leur dire en ce moment je
prends pas ma voiture je voudrais me
réduire un petit peu mon assurance parce
que mine de rien j'ai j'ai aucun risque
alors ces deux choses différentes entre
la perte d'exploitation pour une
entreprise et l'auto mais ils ont fait
des économies en ce moment et certains
ont de manière proactive annuler les
cotisations
c'est ce que certains font aussi pour
les entreprises et de toute manière s'il
gagne de l'argent il rétribue rond dans
les dents les cotisations à long terme
j'essaie d'être factuel j'essaye de
vraiment répondre objectivement d'autres
donc julien pour résumer pour nos
téléspectateurs
les assurances ne vont pas pouvoir tout
prendre en charge donc forcément vous
dit que il ya un dans le contrat
d'assurance il ya deux choses qui sont
pas présents siens c'est les guerres et
les pandémies donc là c'est une vraie
vraie info ways to me oui j'aime
beaucoup notre ami julien mais quand il
dit que les assureurs sont très généreux
c'est peut-être un peu populiste ce que
je dis mais d'après moi pour moi les
assurés s'en sortent toujours y paye
mais après c'est nous qui payons les
contrats plus cher les analystes
toujours sur leurs pattes c'est nous qui
les payons toujours les dommages à les
assurer
qu'est ce que vous dites là comme l'état
aujourd'hui va couvrir tout il aura lé
bon le bon rôle
c'est nous qui allons payer après aussi
là les assureurs ils sont ils sont juste
dans une réponse déjà prudentes parce
qu'ils savent pas à quelle hauteur situe
le problème mais ils disent juste nous
en tout cas on n'avait pas été on avait
pas cotisé pour cette focale a
maintenant je dis qu'ils sont très
généreux parce qu'ils le sont plus que
les autres entreprises cetc voilà c'est
juste ça très bien alors elle mais n'a
pas donné et nous a pas donné de bonnes
nouvelles
mine de rien et julien sur les
assurances que vous voyez dans les
contrats donc on vous le redit pandémie
et guerre ça n'est pas pris en charge
merci julien d'avoir été avec nous
julien filles oh merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là parce que c'est un petit point
assurances et c'est vrai que c'est une
question que tout le monde se pose et
merci beaucoup et bravo plus physique
bravo le très belles pièces
bravo bravo juillet